welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today right
now we are at a crucial point in the
lead up in the run-up to the 2018
midterm elections everybody's kind of
starting to get focused on this we have
Congress that is just a week or so away
from taking their August recess assuming
they're even allowed to because you know
they've already threatened to take that
away from them because they don't want
Democrats to be able to go campaign
nonetheless August should be when these
campaigns really start heating up we're
gonna hit the last of the primaries and
we're gonna know what's what basically
at this point so as we approach the last
of the primaries as we hit August
campaign season here's what we have to
realize this young generation the
youngest generation of voters right now
those between the ages of 18 and 29
voter registration for that particular
age group is surging in the United
States and has been since February of
this year so what happened in February
of this year that suddenly made young
voters decide to get out their register
and get active the answer is the Marjory
Stoneman Douglas high school shooting
when that happened and when the
survivors became active got out there
got on the media got on social media and
gained hundreds of thousands of
followers overnight because of their
outspokenness and their willingness to
call out the politicians who are
beholden to the NRA they made a massive
difference they have gone on to help
with voter registration drives they're
out there talking about it as frequently
as possible they are helping to drive
this voter registration surge that is
happening in the United States today
here's another thing though in the state
of Florida alone I think the the surge
in that 18 to 29 age group has been
close to 40%
other states were receiving the surf
search Pennsylvania Rhode Island New
York Virginia Indiana Arizona those
states are obviously a little behind
Florida with their 40% but they're still
surging in those states some blue some
red but it's not just the school
shootings that these kids have had to
deal with growing up and the uniqueness
of that it is the issue of climate
change it is the issue of student loan
debt it is the issue of healthcare for
most of us and I'm I'm still considered
a millennial I've you know towards the
upper end of that but still a millennial
but for most of my life at least during
my college years all through that and
before I never had to think about or
worry about health insurance not once in
my entire life and that is not a unique
situation for people in my age range
however once I was no longer on my
parent's insurance yeah things got messy
they still are I'm a father my kids have
insurance it costs a hell of a lot of
money certainly lot more than it did for
my parents back in the day even when
adjusted for inflation but these kids
understand that they're coming into a
market for health insurance that may be
completely unaffordable they are gonna
try to go to college and not rack up 40
50 60 thousand or more dollars worth of
debt but more importantly they're just
hoping that they can live long enough to
make it to that point and the biggest
threat that they face are the issues of
school shootings which again this is
unique to this particular age group yes
school shootings have existed for
decades but never with the frequency and
intensity of what we have seen just in
the last few years and when these
politicians out there refuse to act on
it these students get mad these
politicians are telling us that the
money they get and the support that they
get from the
NRA is more important than the lives of
these students let me tell you and I
know this because my wife recently she's
a teacher she's off for the summer but
before the school year ended they had to
go through an active shooter drill and
training with just the staff the
students were not there one of the
things that these teachers are told that
they have to do is when the shooter in
the enters the school they barricade
themselves in the classroom with their
students students have to protect
themselves you put desks up basically
you try to create body armor out of
whatever sitting around the room there
and here's the sickest part if the
teacher after locking and barricading
the door hears or sees a student in the
hallway outside their door screaming
crying being shot begging to get into
their classroom to get safe they are
forbidden from opening the door to let
that student in they sit there and they
watch that person died my wife mentioned
that upon hearing that and being taught
that everything in that room changed
every single teacher sat there in horror
as they were being told that hey when
you hear that person screaming you just
gotta let it happen because you can't
risk the lives of everybody else that is
again unique to this 18 to 29 year old
generation that is getting more
politically active and they need to be
they deserve to be think of how screwed
up everything is in this country right
now and I am NOT just talking about what
Trump has done things were bad before
him I think these kids deserve it these
young Americans these adults these
Patriots whatever you want to call them
it's their turn we have screwed things
up so badly as a country and not just on
the issue of school shootings the issue
climate
is hugely important for this age group
that's something they have lived with
their entire lives meanwhile most of us
in this country climate change wasn't
something we dealt with in childhood
summers were so mild even where I live
in the state of Florida summers were
still so mild she could go outside and
not die of heatstroke but we're seeing
an increase in the amount of heat stroke
deaths all across this country it
occasionally would snow where I'm at in
Florida in the winter those days are
gone because of the rising temperatures
the rising sea levels that are taking
away our coastlines the beach here that
is 20 minutes from where I'm sitting
right now is lost about half of its
landmass just during my lifetime and
that's going to continue 20-30 years it
won't exist anymore but here's the thing
these kids understand it and I hate to
call them kids I do not mean that in a
derogatory way this group these citizens
these Patriots understand it they see
these things they want to fix these
things whether they're left or right or
libertarian or Green Party it doesn't
matter as much to them they see the
problems they've lived with the problems
they live with them every day and
they're sick and tired of these
politicians in DC that aren't doing
anything about it